a good buddy of mine Dr cashy taught an
autistic kid how to read he came to
train the child on how to read with a
bag of Skittles when the kid would read
a word he would give them a Skittle when
he would read more words in a row than
he ever had a record he would give him
two Skittles so he rewarded the behavior
and then he had big bonus rewards when
he would unlock a new level he kept
doing that and within one afternoon he
had him reading a full page it doesn't
have to be complex it's just what is the
behavior that I want to reward how can I
reward more of it now none of it was
punishing he didn't smack him when he
messed up when he read less he still
gave him one to reward him for the
activity and then when he read more he
gave him extra reward and what happens
over time is that the Skittles become a
proxy for approval because then you
collect the Skittles cuz you know that
this means you did a good job